Didn’t use a toilet seat cover in that public
restroom?
You may regret it
Hi guys, Crystal here for DNews.
Are you afraid of contracting a terrible disease
from using a public restroom?
How dirty are those toilets really? and how
useful are those annoying paper covers that
always tear and then fall into the bowl after
you’ve set them down anyway?
Well, according to modern science, those paper
covers, don’t actually do very much…
Concern over the possibility of contracting
disease from public restrooms has been around
for over 100 years.
US patents for “sanitation covers for latrine
seats” date back as far as 1911 and I believe
it was the late great Louis Pasteur* one of
the founders of germ theory who said: “Women,
it is best to hover when peeing” (*Louis
Pasteur definitely did NOT say this).
We know bathrooms and kitchens are a hotbed
of bacteria and other microorganisms due to
the abundance of moisture and nutrients.
Toilet seats are known hang outs for disease
agents like E. coli, strep- and, staphylococcus
bacteria, and the common cold but studies
have shown that the toilet bowl isn’t the
worst offender when it comes to germs -- I
will never eat off of anything touched by
a kitchen sponge again.
Also, unless you have an open sore or other
breach in the protective body casing that
is your skin, the chance of disease transmission
through toilet seat use is slim.
People have gotten their knickers in a bunch
over the safety of toilet seats when a few
cases of sexually transmitted diseases cropped
up in individuals who claimed that they could
not have contracted their infections through
the usual manner.
Dirty toilet seats were blamed but scientists
have repeatedly refuted this conclusion on
the grounds that the infectious agents are
not viable for long outside a host body and
transmission requires direct contact with
mucosal membranes.
Actually, according to a paper in the journal
of Applied and Environmental Microbiology
you are far more likely to get sick by breathing
the aerosolized bacteria in water droplets
from your flush than you are from copping
a squat.
There is a psychological factor at work here
though.
For some people, the act of using a disposable
seat cover just makes them feel safer and
that’s hard to argue with.
But if you’re looking for habits more conducive
to disease prevention than using a toilet
seat cover wash your hands with soap and water.
Yep, that’s it.
That’s the best way to avoid getting sick
from the use of a public restroom is to wash
your hands.
Also when possible, close the toilet seat
cover before you flush.
(or at least don’t stand with your face
over the toilet when you do).
So what have we learned?
Toilets are not the worst offenders of disease
transmission and Nature has once again beat
out Man in efficient engineering of sanitary
barriers through the evolution of skin.
So let us know what you think!
Are toilet seat covers a wasteful american
phenomenon or necessary precaution?
Subscribe to DNews and let us know in the
comments.
Also check out this video where I list my
five favorite things about pee: